highly anticipated sequel a quiet place
part two opened in
theaters last week raking in about 50
million dollars between friday and
sunday it's the biggest
box office debut since the start of the
pandemic
the thriller about mysterious creatures
that hunt by
sound is expected to earn close to 60
million dollars by the end of the
holiday weekend
actor killian murphy joined the cast of
the sequel
as emmett an old friend of the abbott
family
from the first quiet place movie take a
look
did you ever think to come for us
no
the people that are left what they've
become
you don't know do you
well i do
another kind of people worth saving
a scary good film killian murphy joins
us now from dublin island good morning
killian
thanks so much for being with us i love
the first i love the first film
i love this one just as much i know you
were a big fan of the first film
and actually wrote an email to john
krasinski that you didn't end up sending
but what did you say
well i just said exactly that that i
love the movie so much it was my
favorite movie of um
2018 i think it was the first one came
out yeah and uh
i just said congratulations you know i
was a fan of his work beforehand
and i just i wrote congratulations and
then i just got too nervous and i never
said it how did you end up getting this
part
well at the same time it seems that
um himself and emily were watching peaky
blinders at home at the same time and he
was writing the script and he thought of
me for that role so he reached out to me
then about a year later
is it i mean one of the things that i
know it's acting and you have to have to
act
under any circumstance but in a lot of
cases here you're dealing with
essentially cgi monsters who are
terrifying
on the screen but you don't actually see
them in person how challenging is that
well i guess that's our job really as
actors to use our imagination that's
what what we do
and it was quite liberating that there
was no green screen
ever it was all um you know real
locations
and it would be just john saying they're
behind you either common or look this
way it was
pretty basic really kelly and i have to
i have to say
one of the most poignant moments in the
movie was seeing
you on that boat dock and it was a
reference
to millicent's character uh and
the i don't want to give it away but the
fact that you had opened up
and tried to get to know this character
a little bit
better earlier on uh i'm curious for
millicent that
that experience working with her
who she is death uh was was it
challenging and how did it challenge you
to move beyond
i gotta say it was an education working
with her she's phenomenal you know an
incredible performer incredible presence
which i think is something that you
can't
learn as an actor you just have it and
she has that
and uh we got on brilliantly throughout
the shoot
and what i what i always see in young
performers is this sort of instinct
you know which as an older actor you
tend to you're always reaching for a
pure instinct in them
younger performers have it and she just
is
really phenomenal it's kind of her movie
really i think it is her movie
i have to ask is is there going to be a
sequel
um i believe i believes i believe so i'm
not the guy to ask
gillian uh jerica duncan here thank you
again for joining us what a
transformation you've made to see you
like this and see you in the movie it's
completely
different but one of the things that you
brought up is that your performance and
peaky
binder blinders excuse me uh is what
sort of led you or connected you to the
quiet place
too we're we know that you'll be taping
your final season the sixth season
uh what can we expect what can you tell
us we just actually wrapped on friday so
it's done
done now um i i again i you know i
i'm sure you guys are the same as me i'm
not i'm not into spoilers
um and i'm i'm kind of loath to give
anything away but
it will it will it will conclude the tv
series i think
it will be very um very uh
big themes we're exploring and i think
the word i've been using is gothic i
think it's quite gothic
on the last season
a decade working on on peaky blinders
what was it like rapping after all that
um it was emotional for sure um
for a variety of reasons but you know
it's been a big
chunk of my life and i you know i never
expected to go
on a journey with a character like this
and um
uh yeah it's very very big part big part
of me and
the crew and the cast we've become very
very close so
i don't think i've quite absorbed it all
yet if you know what i mean yeah i
imagine it takes a little time for it to
set in and obviously it hasn't come out
yet so you've still got to promote it so
it's still part of your life
but yeah but i mean when they i mean
having just watched the the
the friends anniversary and some of the
some of the the film from when they all
said goodbye got it gets very emotional
because you become a family as you say
yeah for sure i i there was a peaky
blinders
moment that kind of peeled over into a
quiet place
too you want to tell us about that it it
involves a bar
and a bachelorette party and emily blunt
[Laughter]
yeah emily emily saved me there there
tends to be um
it's become this kind of phenomenon
where you people have piggy blinders
weddings and pee
pee blinders you know stag parties and
you guys call them bachelorette parties
we call them hen parties
so that stuff goes on and i should
definitely definitely not be involved in
any of those so
they whisked me away he would have been
the star of the show killian murphy
thank you so much for joining us
we appreciate it it's a great film